all right well we're set to go welcome
everyone to the Jenna and Julian podcast
yeah our special guest this week the
gabbie show Gabi show and other guest is
Gabi's headphones yes that's the real
guest Gabi's just kind of here to bring
the headphones I think it's funny that
I'm a guest on this show that like the
most irrelevant that's a joke you sell
yourself short
Gabi is on vine she is in the gabbie
show on vine
so she makes vines 82 and you know
that's right in YouTube so full time
doing vine YouTube mhm and we met her at
know funny story at me at playlist but
okay what did happen was back when I was
even more super irrelevant I met you and
Jenna VidCon and I took a picture and I
posted it and I was really excited and I
wrote a really snappy caption to the
picture that was basically like oh my
god Jenna's the reason I started doing
this stuff in the first place like I
already so savvy I know like and then we
were at the streamys and I tweeted
oh yeah Alex or not the fangirl over
Jenna yeah
nan Jenna says oh my god I wish I could
have met you and I was like oh I guess
you can remember
you tricked me right from the start so
we all sort of at least you two sort of
go way back without even really knowing
it we didn't know at all you didn't know
it and then playlist was where where we
started hit it off like that's why we
made the love Kimmy yeah that connection
is where happened at the playlist and
that happened there was neither of us to
playlist Secaucus exactly what that's
slow blink that's what we do when yeah
exactly she is now she just mastered it
before I even described it you just
killed the slow blink it was not only
did people hate it but like our light
just broke that you've seen all right we
really did that that happened but why
did you think putting flash leap on the
floor it worked it worked like that much
honestly I didn't care if you liked this
video so juvenile Mike I'll give no
[ __ ] because I want to slow blink from
now on and yeah people wanted me to play
that exactly you know people tell you
the videos that's like the the video
itself wasn't the prettiest or the most
glamorous or most popular video but it
needed to be out you had to make it
there's no oh well now the world knows
and I know the slow blink is one of the
best defenses for anything ever ever so
and it's so insulting every time oh so
and so it's really degrading very common
because because they they're trying to
formulate what insult you're saying in
your head but they can this they can't
cuz your eyes are shut they can't even
see
exactly
so we are in our new room which is
exciting
we sound proved it's sort of soundproof
yeah we put up a whole entire wall of
foam it's not really house where and
yeah we have a little little work to do
in the soundproofing department but yeah
we got some cool fan out behind us which
you guys are so town I've hit like this
one it blows my mind I think Kristen is
her name is who did this yeah that's
insane no Kristen did that one's hair
Stern dude the one in the hoodie with ya
sir no sir I know you anywhere family
exactly
and unfortunately we haven't been able
to figure out exactly the best way to
stream to Ustream while we do this so
once we figure that out we'll do that
yeah sometimes we stream it live and we
call them our Seger family so they can
like watch us and they like comment on
you and we're in a new setup but we'll
figure out how to do that it shall
happen yeah anyways anyway can you talk
about gas talk about let's talk about
Rowdies our neighbor
we're like Valley neighbors yeah we are
which is pretty weird it's pretty cool
though because it's like it's like a
secret family in the valley right
[ __ ] so you moved here from
Pittsburgh mm-hmm and you drove your
2001 Buick it might be a 2002 so that's
take a little kind of you guys share
that 2002 Honda across the country
[Music]
nothing but hope and a prayer
she drove her I was just watching that
video but she drove 36 hours with Alex
James was awesome
good Alex means there's just no it's
just
Alex hey Alex yeah that was a nightmare
yeah that entire wave just because they
was with him or because no can you tell
half the story it's ridiculous I want
punch to the back half the story I'm
gonna give a long story short okay that
video is so long okay yeah that's it so
basically Alex calls me and he's he
wanted me to get to LA and I kept saying
you know I I need time I need to figure
out I want to I'm not bringing this car
I need to figure out how to ship my
stuff and need to pack it whatever and
he ends up calling me ten minutes later
and he says hey pack your car pick me up
at the airport at 8 a.m. and we're
driving to California it was like Alex I
Drive a 2000 Buick I can't do that she's
like I would it'll be fine we'll figure
it out so I packed my Buick and I picked
up at the airport and right off the bat
you just like falls asleep but I'm like
okay that's fine because he's gonna have
to drive soon so I Drive 12 to 14 hours
by myself sure that there's straight-up
easily gone so I wake him up and like he
and then I take a charger comes up on my
package 24 hours at this point and I'm I
tell him to wake up he gets all sassy
Gonzalez's ask if you know Alex isn't it
goes well all right well I'll probably
just drive first away then two hours he
wakes me up again it goes I think you
need to take your turn doesn't even
exist yet I would have punched him I
thought about that tank
four times he got a quarter tank home to
take my turn understand it was right guy
and he said well you got the easy hours
and I was like what is he there's no
such I guess 14 easy hours of driving
across the country ya know then the tire
exploded and that was so you had you got
ripped off by that guy right no he
actually hit me good he was like I'm
gonna give you a good deal to give me
cash and they gave you like a couple of
bucks off he did say that he was going
to give me a better deal if I walked
across a four-lane highway
and came back me to about two dollars oh
my [ __ ] snake man yes but you know
what it's fine he gave me a good deal
it's fine it's fine it's fine don't
worry about it
so before that though you lived in
Pittsburgh did you grow up there well I
actually from Newcastle but nobody knows
what that is you you said that to me in
Jersey you're from England New England
yeah are New Caledonia New Jersey New
Castle Pennsylvania not even the New
Jersey one no no it's just a really sad
town why is that is it just small
western North at Pennsylvania's huge
where where on the Pennsylvania
Pittsburgh is Western PA and Newcastle
is also a certain PA but slightly north
so it's basically Pittsburgh we have the
same yeah yeah you in that part of
Pittsburgh or the state are you the are
you the people that put the [ __ ] else
on the ends of words Saul I saw that
yeah yeah we do that we do a lot of
really I'm not just things like we say
Steelers well I don't but my dad and my
grandma do like the Steelers still their
killer so like every eternal sellers we
call our shopping carts buggies I don't
know if it's a Pittsburgh thing as much
as it's like a nice sounds like a
foreign thing yeah I'm from the East
Coast we do not call [ __ ] buggies we put
french fries thank you maybe they call
it buggies in England which Newcastle is
in the real new cut that's just it's all
stretch buggies that sounds like an
English I've heard it's like where you
get the water that my mama said well the
East Coast does have like crazy ass
[ __ ] lingo they are Boston more than
anywhere Boston they still call liquor
stores pakis like a package that's right
you were telling me that you're telling
me that yeah like drinking fountains or
bubblers bubblers are you guys say like
that Julian its bubbler as a bubbler you
got a bubble on the way a pass game
yeah can I get a large eyes hold on this
is Jenna
as a Bostonian ordering from Dunkin
Donuts go can I get a large ice pack
roast espresso double shot but I didn't
even say that I forget what it's called
turbo shot - styrofoam a powder x-ray
extra twist twist 11 twist 11 Splenda I
need extra large one of those dumb cups
and the whipped cream on the top it can
you sprinkle chocolate sprinkles on the
jimmies brilliant that was really good I
feel like I'm watching a middle-aged
Bostonian woman I kid you not I saw
someone in [ __ ] Dunkin Donuts porter
that like they're just a neighbor that's
where that came from that impression
well thank you for that especially me
stop [ __ ] that I love when you take
care that's super boss you better
[ __ ] that kid we used to say that
when we first met you're crushing it god
yes is a guy yeah what's up guy hey guys
I mean guy anyway you got me sorry so
you grew up you do know your way wait so
you knew castles where you were born and
raised I was born and raised there and
then I went to school at Pitt inter okay
I wanted to be God at first to study
wait can we timeout for one second
because I have so much respect for
people that decide to work in Internet
and or entertainment but take the time
to [ __ ] school go to college to be
fair I didn't plan to work on the
Internet so when you graduated from Pitt
I did oh good for you I just feel like I
know a lot of people yeah I know a lot
of people that I like I was there I
didn't have to make that choice like
college or work on the internet because
wasn't an option didn't happen until
after graduate yeah yeah which I'm
grateful for that is gonna have the
relief as am i good [ __ ] god but I
just feel like it's really important for
people to finish their education and
it's hard for me to take people say
seriously when they were like you had
you know dropped out of high school I
mean obviously obviously there are
exceptions but yeah exceptions like
there's I know some kids who dropped out
of high school to pursue the internet
and they're making like great if you
drop out of high school to go have a
career great if you drop out of high
school so that you can work a part-time
job and smoke weed all day not so much
not so much it's just I mean it yeah it
doesn't be a loser DD man and you know
what like you went you might as well see
it through I have a lot of respect for
people that are in the internet that
have education it just it gives you a
college graduate party you know ascends
himself of who you are
yeah for sure I would be a completely
different person yeah Newcastle was one
of the most sheltered towns in the
entire world can I please tell you that
I did not realize until I went to
college and this wasn't just a meeting
this was a like a very general Newcastle
thing people in Newcastle don't realize
that there's races besides black and
white get the [ __ ] that's right not for
real though they know like more I mean
like we know that like George look at it
for you you know white like Chinese
people if somebody asks you know what
ethnicity women oh they're white because
I believe in come on out if we met you
know like I'm Mexican person so going to
be going up it was like oh there's a
world out there well I said I forget how
I'd like first discovered this but this
girl said something about like being
Asian yeah and then I think and then oh
she said something about white girls and
she said like oh like like haha you're
such a white girl I was like you're a
white girl - she's like
[Laughter]
also learned that like Indian people are
also considered Asian which I never
would have guessed in a million years
what's in it yeah because it's it's sad
that I didn't know that until I went to
I went to college to learn that there
were people weird
obviously above anything you learn life
things that cause every I mean it's like
life experience well there's a lot of
places like that small town America
where the first time that you're exposed
to other people other cultures as
college which among many things is a
good reason to go yeah that shaped me as
a human if I didn't go to Pitt I would
be such a [ __ ] monster I don't think
I'd be a very cool person and I was also
emo and I'm hoping that I would have
grown out of that anyways though I think
College you were emo so usually I don't
have a [ __ ] oh my god I am where's my
phone my phone is right so many pictures
like you'll die when our user cares
explained us yeah just why don't you
paint them for us okay I was like you
know in my space like there was like a
scene yes yes I was that kid yes the
book I was Gabba saw Rex died no kidding
just keep going keep going you shouldn't
get him I see him
yeah I think it's just a fun it's down
oh my god oh my god stop it
oh my god there's gum on the table yeah
there's guys I killed him that
[ __ ] was in our territory this
is a brand-new studio how dare him think
he can just walk up in here and even get
some real estate in the podcast um I
just was really seen I had really black
hair and really think swept bangs and I
leggings
looks like newspaper work if I show you
some of the pictures that I edited for
myspace oh you have those there on my
phone oh they're hot okay so we're gonna
get to see him later not really maybe
she'll link them somewhere I have a
question how did people react to first
of all what kind of name is show the gap
last name show so Gabi's your middle
name okay no that actually happened when
I was a kid people would make fun of me
and because I had like really bad ADHD
and I was like really cool all the time
and they would be like oh here comes the
gabbie show and it would make me feel
Orion their [ __ ] faces yeah and
then I was a kid and I actually well I
made the gabbie show my Twitter handle
years later somebody I was the gabbie
show on Twitter before I was anything
okay so is okay but there's this footage
of me as a really awkward like chubby
not good-looking kid and I have a
camcorder because I used to carry a
camcorder with me and I'm in the mirror
and it's so dramatic I turn to the
mirror to go
welcome to the GAVI show and I was just
like entertaining myself because I don't
have any friends so now I just like
that's the greatest story literally and
you know what those people know who the
[ __ ] and this subtle [ __ ] you they they
remember they look at you know by now
the most popular one one of those
probably their Viners ever and you're
like well you're like the top five items
like a name on one like well I'm
actually ranked 112 butters give a drag
because like Justin Bieber has a [ __ ]
vine and he's what you mean even though
we've learned and we've learned that
people will recognize Gabi over Justin
Bieber right because I I post a lot and
I like yeah and also if you're on that a
lot he does actually look weight so if
just hypothetically if I were like
hiking somewhere and I saw Gabby
whoo yeah that's what I'm doing I'm
gonna make it into a youtube video I
think cuz that's the way it happened was
funny okay by the way you guys have
already noticed this but she is one of
the most epic storytellers we've ever
met she was not restricted by this table
and chair
I bet she'd add body language so yeah
okay so I met Runyan and it's funny
because my friend had just told me she's
friends with Justin and she said oh yeah
Justin goes to Runyon all the time and
then the first time I went hiking after
that which is not often just kidding I
actually take a lot because like I make
myself feel like I'm doing something so
I go hiking and I see this kid who is
kind of you know sure and he has
bleached blond hair and I'm like that's
[ __ ] Justin Bieber so I turned my
path and I started going the other
direction and I followed him because
done so is a really awkward thing where
I'm super out of shape let me catch my
breath holy [ __ ] they're passing me this
is embarrassing sprint sprint sprint
sprint sprint oh my god I'm dead again
so I kept doing this thing where was
like their group of people and that's
high-intensity interval training yeah I
know they're right behind me and then
they're right in front of me and this is
them
this is them walking it like a really
normal study person pace
that's funny eventually I say okay this
is an embarrassing let me just say a few
steps behind them hope I stay behind
them for a while and they're like
everyone's freaking out about no it's a
very sense of it really does yeah that's
great so I'm really exploit just I
really don't care that much like that I
see them and I'm not like fangirling or
anything at this point I'm just like
okay this is embarrassing I'm breathing
really heavily and they see me really
sweaty and if I did meet Justin Bieber
today I would prefer it not be in the
situation so I let him go ahead of me a
little bit but then they stopped and
they're like overlooking I'm like okay
this is my chance so I go and then I
usually go the other way around but when
I saw Justin Bieber I turned around
because I'm a freak
and then I never went this path before
and it's like the steps I normally go up
or now down and I have no traction on my
shoes and Runyon is super sandy so I'm
like oh my god I'm gonna fall I'm
literally gonna die so I'm jumping down
alarmingly slow pace and then they catch
up to me again and I turned around to
Kendall Jenner who I did not realize was
kendall Jenner with Bieber didn't
realize it was her somebody he posted a
picture with her and they're like oh my
god that was kendall Jenner and I got my
gotta talk to Kendall
so she's right behind me and I'm really
slow and I'm really embarrassed at this
point so I turn around to kind of look
and I say hey I'm embarrassing
embarassingly out of shape I'm about to
bust my ass on these stairs so if you
want to go ahead of me you can and she
goes oh no it's fine so they're behind
me the whole time I can feel myself
holding up their posse because the sores
are like oh my god this is awful
so we finally get to the bottom of the
stairs and this girl screams oh my god
and I'm like Jesus like let this boy
hike and she says are you happy show it
I was like amazing
so I've never felt cooler in my entire
life and she was just like I love you
thank you for putting your
out there and the whole time I'm just
like is he looking does he hear what's
going on he knew he knew yeah okay so
he's a 59 I checked million Twitter's
Twitter followers that's not even it I
think Katy Perry has more she does Katy
Perry is like the Beast of Twitter yeah
fifty nine million
it's not even a real number click the
follow line my account got hacked the
fifty nine mil what my account got
hacked at the time so you had hacked and
then you have to I know I had fifty nine
mil and Justin Bieber actually hacked my
account I actually lost all of my fifty
nine million in the purge so well the
second one has Matt Saracen in it and
yeah I know you I know so I know she's
in Friday Night Lights fan I've seen her
tweets we are as big of Friday Night
Lights fans thank you have you seen the
movie I actually never I mean either I
think that's something I should do on
the unit it's not really I would do it I
might need ask me some what at the same
race I thought it was complete I thought
buddy garrison or whatever Garrity is
the only character aside Connie Britton
maybe that was me Taylor oh my god your
tweet you were like damn Tami Taylor's
annoying but them titties knows about
Julie Taylor
Oh
boy worth did you notice she's learned
every sentence with a Sutter
she starts every single sentence weird
because that's [ __ ] acting no you and
I both got as annoyed with Julie Taylor
nice what like what do you don't love me
sleeping with it okay though but ours to
her defense she was the only one of the
only cast members that was actually the
age she was supposed to be so you know
okay yeah whatever
she's better than Disney Channel acting
I think she grew up to be really hot -
she's very pretty but like Minka Kelly
was like [ __ ] 30 on this she she's
hurt but it was not a high school
student that she she's yeah I'm in love
with why every man on that show okay you
know what Jenna's car's name is buddy
Garrity thank him right my car name
names inspired by that is smash Williams
because he's little and he's black and
he's fast when I buy a new car it's
probably gonna be a Friday night my 2002
good stroke yeah B Saracen remember that
that's right seriously though the Friday
Night Lights god I just love it all
right oh my god it's an epic show I mean
it takes your heart I want to start
watching football because you want to go
to high school football games because of
Friday yeah that place you you want ammo
to Texas if you could have you been
Austin no okay go to Austin you will one
of them to tech I mean that place is we
want to eventually move to Austin okay
yes Jenna all right I probably won't
them
do you remember you might know you
probably will okay you know you know the
scene where their rivals come in and
they're sharing a locker room yes I
think so yes okay and then the was when
they were still the know the Panthers
there's pre Lions and then the coach is
a little punk-ass [ __ ] yes and he takes
Tim Riggins and he grabs me throws him
to the ground and then all of a sudden
like a [ __ ] fairy Coach Taylor comes
out and he grabs on and like dad's drink
protection mode I find it I find that
scene with me just moving in this is the
only room in the house that doesn't
smell like dog so I like the smell of
patients are very they all have cute
sense but their excrements don't peach
like a puppy that's patient's voice no
okay so someone a storyboard artist like
a professional freelance story where
artist creates on she has a youtube
channel and she creates basically she
takes videos and turns them in the
storyboard like cartoons and she did it
for [ __ ] Jenna's old old video what
is the video called what dogs do what
dogs do when you're not home and she's
segue that and it's segwayed too when
peach came and she it's it's amazing I'm
gonna tweet it out I get tweeted out for
the podcast account but it's so cute
okay so cute
dogs oh it's awesome but I was thinking
animated sorry yeah usually drew
everything it's like I don't know maybe
150 drawings yes you just like really
goodness
ripped the audio we created like I'd say
half of the video yeah with the
animation and then changed it to bring
peaches yeah at the end we come home I'm
even in and your eyes are like huge and
spider tails wagging and it has the
voice so cute doesn't your
representation of Paige Paige
except she's been a devil not an angel
like a devil lately with everything
she's she ripped up our new carpet like
calm down peach she a [ __ ] my name is
not because you know for a fact your
name is Paige now okay well that's why I
did this I wish I wouldn't people would
have been so upset if I repeat on this
thing it's not that is does she even
answered a peach anymore she is Paige we
call her Paige like pretty often the
patient's is serving them pay it's so
[Laughter]
funny I just showed my friend you know
just dancin yeah yeah I just showed her
and that's every time I heard her last
name it's like oh the girl he got drunk
with yeah yeah she lives in New York oh
oh [ __ ] I don't have my phone remind me
I could run again if you see what she
sent me an audio okay her singing a
weird beat and she was like what was
that something that Jenna played for us
it was a youtuber it was a boy and then
I thought she was I got echo and I
thought sure's how about rickey dillion
villain yeah so then she sent an audio
of her going did d-does she told me to
ask your
okay well let them decide for them and
it's a youtuber she said was a youtuber
and she said it was a guy so the only
people who watch the iron wakey-wakey
Dylan and yeah I bet it's a kpop video
oh we watch as per you know per every
weekend we watch AOA like a cat those
are like the only English words and then
it's just on the Korean case also a
fancy not really they carry their what
if you have more than working on it more
than one guess we have another Mike it
would just be a matter of rearranging
the seats and getting another seat here
but and also fancy headphones
yeah no honestly no like if we hit that
maybe like a couple or something like on
here we we it's possible that they could
share a mic you know I mean if you're
talking about things yeah when you talk
when you were talking I could hear you
it yeah cuz we're pretty close they all
pick each other up a little bit but
that's why you know you hear the best
audio like songs in here like oh yeah no
these aren't fair yeah it's pretty good
right that's what I'm gonna record a
nightmare feel two point oh my god I put
out an album no I know you just came
here mocking birthday I bought copies
yeah of course you did everyone did
market out here Moloch needs to be on
the podcast sometime yeah for sure
I am forever on genna's radio show they
included a section of the creepy song
and put it as a sweeper out of the
second break of her show every single
week so basically I'm like
like third on the list of theme next -
like Obama number one is Justin Bieber
yeah true yeah well because he's so big
on mine yeah he's really made his career
so science started just me more nothing
without find everyone knows that yeah I
agree
yeah I really thank God for the app like
it really started the borrow you tube
did start that boy that's just true
which was before everything happened it
was like early innocent light boys he
seems like a nice kid though I've been a
Bieber fan ever since I heard like if he
invited me to his party who's gonna say
no to Bieber's party there's a bunch of
riders hanging out there tonight I tried
real hard if anybody asks I turned down
Justin Bieber's party we all did that's
what happened so yeah we're really he
invited Jenna and then Julian really I
mean really guys well let's just like
have a drink in like podcast like
totally casual last minute it's what my
goober driver on the way here I totally
it's for Nona turned out oh my god uber
drivers dude I had an uber X driver last
night and she was this middle-aged woman
and she was like a single mom but I get
into the car well first she like
wouldn't let me and she locks the door
so what's your name I was like Julian
okay get in and she was like and she
turns around whew this is my first ride
and I was like oh okay like she was like
so excited she was very adorable I was
like oh that's great like let's let's do
this and you know she's like she's
talking to me about how she said oh you
want the music you want some hair like
and then she was like they teach us to
do that we're supposed to make you happy
so like let me know if you could do if
sometimes they give you candy yeah she
was like I'm supposed to offer you water
would you like some water she was just
very nice and sweet and I was like I
don't think something are you allowed no
I didn't think you were supposed to but
then I saw a sign over Runyon that I was
like don't forget like uber Zoar service
workers to make sure to tip your uber
was it an uber sign or was it oh it's
fine yeah I don't know why someone will
put up like an external sign you think
though is that you get in the car
you ride all arrived and you just you
know you're charged you know it should
be yeah it's amazing
it should be like I mean if they did
want to include tips which I don't think
they showed because the whole like you
said mystique and like ease of it is
that it's just boom on the app done
amount but if they did they should make
it on that I don't understand how they
make money is it so cheap well yeah
that's what I've just like I went over
the hill all the way to Hollywood and it
was like a 20-minute drive I paid like
$19 I made it from my place in North
Hollywood all the way to deep deep West
Hollywood it was like I think a
45-minute Drive less than 20 bucks
essence it is insane because well there
used to be apps for just regular taxis
that were in price but the apps were
[ __ ] [ __ ] taxi [ __ ] mad which
is now curved you can't [ __ ] hide the
right because yeah the giant [ __ ] on
them but they okay yeah and they offered
us the sponsor the price they sent me an
email maybe one curb is like hey we'd
like to work with you on the podcast
like sponsorship
sorry we can't represent a company like
[ __ ] here you here because the
concept was the same as the taxi drivers
would go and look on their [ __ ]
whatever and go and pick yeah it was
just not done they didn't the individual
taxi drivers didn't want to [ __ ] get
on board so they would just cancel they
would accept your ID and then not show
they would pick someone up on the street
and cancel your [ __ ] ride in the
early days if you would just wait
outside of your house for forty-five
[ __ ] in the early days of taxi magic
you and I had multiple nights where we
literally waited outside for 30 plus
minutes and then nothing happened right
it's because they would see someone
standing on the side of the road and
decided that that was faster yes it
would be all on their custom right yeah
so with uber you're not allowed to just
lock you in waiting you can see where
they are I don't I don't think that it's
like a whole lot cheaper than cabs were
is it really yes I mean at least my
first year here when it lived in Santa
Monica wasn't taking cabs farther than
you know we homemade yeah yeah but you
know I don't I don't really think that I
plate like paid way too much money
yeah taxi if you take a taxi from the
airport telling my place it's well over
$100 what you think usually a flat rates
for that yeah yeah that's the thing go
get you though if you don't come in
there and like hey there's a flat rate
right they're gonna be like oh this
person is no waiting you for rather my
nizzle yeah yeah for the airport yeah
that makes me want to die GameChanger
oh well regardless bird uber is cheaper
anything so whatever where's my main
[ __ ] I do have a free coat on lift
those I'm using I've never used lifts
I've never used it
there's pretty much the same I've heard
it's cool I've heard like you know
something about uber that feels sweet
though I think yeah that was black
they're like oh also people don't like
the moustaches have left I've heard that
from the lyft driver they still do that
it's illegal to put on the outside of
your car but you can keep it on here so
they may be the outline
yeah I guess it was starting to get
weird it wasn't cute it was kind of
pedophile you don't look like mustache
oh the stand-up character for those of
you that live in other places and don't
have lips they basically just had giant
pink car stashes yeah it's kind of part
of the gig yes I guess lips live
something is that they're you know you'd
apps or whatever and you talk to them
and they're not like your driver they're
like your friend sort of right I don't
know maybe I'm wrong I've never think
that was a really accurate I'm sorry I'm
just like thinking of the person
creating lift being like alright guys
here's the plan okay we're not just
gonna drive them we're gonna be their
friends okay so first you gotta do is
you gotta dab some okay like it just
seems ridiculous they're successful
they're good competitor you gotta think
I'm joking the reason that they're
successful is because they're driving
people from A to B not because they're
dousing them but I do appreciate the
customers they are kind they have candy
more often than ooh have you have you
been in a lift
I think I'm trying to order a lift and
then they didn't come oh so you have it
so Jesse uses strictly lived really
strictly stole her we're cold you can't
use it anymore so she use a strictly
lift and she swears that they're better
there's a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's
happened with uber yeah well yeah well
there's also drivers who double as they
were in lyft rappers like you'll meet
them oh I also drive for lyft oh cool
yeah which sounds like very complicated
yeah but they make it seem like oh yeah
just sign on in and I'm working for left
like yeah they make it seem like it's
completely discretionary whatever you
want to work you're working when my vine
career eventually goes down the toilet
fine fine career he's on the toilet
I'm probably gonna become a lyft driver
that's fine there's more female lyft
drivers I've noticed statistically
however last night sober driver was like
one there was a another female over
driver we got from Studio City but other
than that it's been all male yeah my guy
that she passed it's safer I feel like
it's I would be nervous if I was a
female driver that someone would try and
[ __ ] rob me or at least take
advantage yeah sure just seems unsafe
yeah cuz you're a long yeah you know
anytime that young woman working alone
at night it's it's more of a TARDIS like
like a woman passenger which is I guess
you know actually has happened several
times yeah which is that it is sad and
it's just friend that's I used to do
with kit we used to live I've gotta go
in pairs wheeze no you don't have to I
feel like we used to live there's a
couple blocks away from my friend and
she walked home and I'm like all right
we're gonna FaceTime the entire time
yeah me we're on [ __ ] FaceTime I see
it I'm wondering where you are a new way
to do a location [ __ ] true I use it up
but just phone calls we're out cause
like but it would usually just be an
excuse to like call a boy if I shouldn't
be calling so I'd like get drunk and
walk out and be like the gather cells
got kids
I'm junk and I'm walking and it's dark
and I just don't want to get attacked so
I'm just want you to stay on the phone
me about 30 but I'm actually secretly in
my leg room I'm still walking I'm not
that's not a bathtub that's rain
[Laughter]
that's very it's very sensitive table
calm down it's not taking everything so
personally table classic table you know
I'm not here because you're too fat to
get out the door yeah exactly
anyway what else what's up what's so
whoa yeah we noticed that the table like
anything you do to the table is just
kind of like the mic stands are on the
table so anything that so we can put the
mic stem cells oh yeah we got our [ __ ]
[ __ ] we just get some arms that'll be
good to go yeah maybe like a nice couple
of arms four legs arms arms arms get oh
yeah we're gonna kind of call a couple
of arms no I didn't do times you need to
start teaching me how to pick heavy
things up I will teach you John is the
one that each other
do you like diet as well like do you eat
right [ __ ] whoa well that sounded like a
[ __ ] bomb and I was on silent and I
even told her boys Brett I was like
Jenna turning on silent we invited Brett
we'll see what Brett the [ __ ] is doing I
think I think he's got a haircut the
morning stage tired weekend I think
we're gonna go to Home Depot I don't
know a time anyone get that thank you
Julie and I gave you the follow-up I
said I don't know if we'll have time oh
okay I missed that so Touche oh I
thought that you were generally on a
tight schedule
I got toilet paper if a big day tomorrow
go to Bed Bath & Beyond maybe Home Depot
I don't know what did that memo to your
video that's cool oh speaking of which
old school looked at do watch girls I
don't anymore
I don't have cable I don't want you to
get HBO GO no that was my without my
cases password yeah that was my face not
of anything but I was just upset because
[ __ ] I feel like part of me hate
watches girls yeah it became like that
like because I hate what cuz you were
talking contributing okay that's me
contributing in conversation I feel like
part of me watches girls because you
know Lena Dunham had this whole like
voice of a generation I'm like this is
not my voice like I'm not a [ __ ]
entitled [ __ ] that like just [ __ ]
lives off my parents and [ __ ] and
whatever yeah I don't like her character
so the second episode what is your body
of then choose in graduate school and
all of a sudden she's that like a
[ __ ] old school frat party lik
wrestling in the mud I'm like excuse you
this is not what grad school is you
[ __ ] okay but [ __ ] off the whole
episode Jenna Jenna and I have basically
come to the conclusion that nothing
happens every episode the beginning of
the episode is the same as they I'm
sorry the beginning in the episode of
the same as end and there's no
progression it's just like oh hey we
gotta fight yeah if someone Marty came
oh my god it miss girls what happened on
last night's episode you'd be like
nothing not a good show because I know
everything and if if a show is good and
I like a show I will [ __ ] obsessively
watch it until it is over true Friday
Night Lights
i watch religiously true I watched girls
like I have a season and there was
nothing that compelled I don't think
mentioning Friday nights in the same
breath as girls does I just like
watching like this is the thing though
is that I do like watching girls I will
continue to watch well at one point the
show earlier yeah
coccioli oh no so hot did not get enough
[ __ ] airtime boots
yeah Thiago oh my god he was so sexy
where did he go I'm not sure I remember
who that is
he exactly the he didn't get enough air
time he was a little punk buddy Garrity
adopted because he came from jail oh
yeah picked him up oh my god he was okay
disappeared out of my light like a
[ __ ] ghost where'd you go
he went ghost come back T Riggs take the
rap for his brother man
what a good guy yeah I'm like right
where he just got out of jail and I'm
almost finished
oh then he just doesn't talk for like
three episodes he never did anyways yeah
but no he silent tricks I'm sorry for
those of you that have never watched
like three episodes I'm convinced all
Tim Riggins does is just like look
around like broodingly like with his
hair when he's dating [ __ ] Tyra yeah
remember that usually dated Tyra for
like a second his hair is all like his
hair is always wet it's always right
here first season like the first three
episodes oh yeah oh so upset I don't
[ __ ] Julie Taylor comes in yeah she
[ __ ] her teacher and then he like
she's like oh my god your wife I knew
that but now I'm sad about it and then
those wave attacks and attacks are the
chillers are like drops out of college
[ __ ] your tips together Julie your tits
that's all you'll ever amount to is your
luscious wonderful tips you can always
go to the landing strip for a career you
know what else is unrealistic that [ __ ]
just had bangs from her sophomore year
of high school to her straight up okay I
did but nobody do me to know that thank
you dear Bhangra no yep I could have
bangs you got a mean man going on no
those are not bangs that's just hair
which is always
I think we all have bangs then yeah
there's some cool stuff back there these
all come in the middle yeah and we're
not done we got to go check the peel box
and move our pol box to the valley and
then you bring everything with you and
you move like everything you've gotten
any real action yeah except we haven't
gone to check out Noel so we gotta go do
that yeah I really want to set one up
but I don't think anyone would send
anything I would sense that's your Bo
box yeah the guys view of our position
I've got one time and there'd be like
some type of vibrator in there somebody
would send me like dirty babies that
would send you and empty it at like
envelope and be like this is all ya be
put it in here will you please mail me
your use panties in here yo it's already
a selfie don't discourage her she'll get
some fish you can't you get love man
but yeah ya know what we got a look at
the valley cuz RPO box is literally in
Santa Monica that's why we never go
you can't you forward it to you yeah we
have to do that we haven't done that yet
it's like a hassle that's why I said I'm
a Buick actually because it's that well
besides the fact that I don't want to
buy a new car but in order to get a new
car act like become a California
resident mm-hmm that's so much work well
you know I think legally if you've lived
here for longer than 30 days you have to
do that Gaby what are you doing or are
you an alien I'm a legal alien I'm dead
serious
I know it well I think it's three months
are you sure I'm pretty sure it's three
months but maybe it's changing it's
where you came I know some people that
have lived here for a long time I plan
on doing it I really do it's so much
work just do it it's really not I
thought they'd make it much harder like
on the East Coast you had to bring like
five pieces of [ __ ] mail and like all
this [ __ ] you need to either your birth
certificate or your social security card
you don't need that here you
literally just need like you know one
piece of mail that proves your address
and they don't even care
it says I specifically asked when I
moved here I was like do you not care
that I don't have like all these bills
in my name or whatever
yeah to prove my address and they're
like no we'll take your word for it we
just you know give us your money like
you're a California resident you can't
be a you know multiple yeah right you
surrender your license they don't give a
[ __ ] so just go do it I have to get my
license yeah they take your old one oh
they punch a hole in it yeah that's yeah
oh just like a punch the hole like find
that thing ain't grab it I mean I have
to anyways because I've been filling out
all my w9 w 9o my w9z yeah yeah
eventually I'm going to have to get
efficient I need to get Bertha is on her
last legs I'll tell you why your car
Bertha yeah she's on the last damn leg
she is like I get in her and like you
could feel her side she's like when she
limps all the way it's too bad that you
weren't in the market for a 2002 Honda
Accord because I just sold that yeah so
that's really I mean it's like a
one-year upgrades yeah but basically oh
those still twelve years old that's 20
my car's older so you have a little
brother did your makeup yes I had a
little I have five sisters and one
brother yeah what kind of my face I've
been begging my mom since forever
she's like you know you have a brother
in verse 60 but I'm still waiting for my
younger brothers he might go IVA nice
though so that counts it works yeah you
love your niece she loves you too it's
really cute
greatest silver I'm two for two and
holding your knees and making a crab all
times oh that's okay my knees and she
cries - yeah that's it's our little
thing we have relationship it's just
like a classic knees it's normal in the
early you know you have like a bit a bun
and she yeah she's like what machine is
that and also on how they were like
right before naptime which is bad yeah
she's grumpy there's always a reason
it's never I think one time though she
did knock a tower of blocks that I bet
though up so like basically were best
friends right did you see my mind of
trying to hold my knees no it was a
really dramatic but I kept trying to
hold my knees and she would literally
just put her arms up and rode a large
Pig and she used to be my best friend
she used to love me I would go to
Harrisburg and like she would love the
[ __ ] out of me and we're best friends
and then I moved to California and then
she grew up from six months to a year
yeah and she forgot about me so I made
this vine where I like reach for it I go
come here Gemma and she runs away and
it's like a montage you don't even trip
probably shoot a year like a month yeah
February
how long have been the zoo sinner we
started did you remember you they get
over it because now me and Gemma are
best friends again and we have a few
pictures of her on my shoulder and she
hits me in the face that means your
friends cool that's really so when
babies hit you in your mouth your
friends yeah
Oh aunt Annies do you have any sisters
or brothers yeah I have an older sister
younger brother and then three step
siblings but none of them are gonna have
kids soon I don't think I'll probably
the first time you never know maybe
maybe my sister I'll have kids before me
I don't I don't know she's in school
she's focus she's not gonna have kids
soon wait before you before me you're
right
I'm showing someone told me I was
showing today the nation no nobody said
to me are you pregnant or just chubby
and I answered both and now people need
anything I'm pregnant
oh my god you can't feed the trolls man
[ __ ] that do you have to say that I hate
comments video I'm gonna make because I
saw yours and I have one I've been
collecting my hate comments for like a
year there are so crazy
just so you guys know I gave him a big
hug after that because that was Ralph
people are mean you gotta wear no laughs
though no that's a but she did and you
did it wasn't feeling bad at all but
everyone who watched her who loved
generals Lincoln yeah but I wrote I
wrote a blog post about it like it was
people are getting confused between the
sad music and the my delivery of it yeah
I was trying to keep on theme with you
the original idea yeah people were like
you seemed really sad like no it was
just kind of you know the way that I
chose well you you read it in a funny
way where it's like oh well I didn't
know it I feel like if you don't have a
thick skin like I would have closed my
[ __ ] computer years ago yeah mm-hmm
I'm totally fine and do it it's fun yeah
it's entertaining cuz that someone are
funny the first time I went to read out
those was I was seeing this guy and I
was really upset because this is when I
first started online and it was like I
think I had probably 125 thousand
followers I was like fresh and I was
getting all of these made the comments
at once
and somebody's comment was I thought
that she was thinner with this with the
distressed face like the one that's like
like if they were genuinely hurt that I
was like fat so this I read I showed it
to him you're not even what you don't
[ __ ] fat and I like to say I am just
it's funny they know I'm not that but
like I get why like a I get why an 11
year old girl who is used to seeing
really skinny women would look at me and
sad that you know what I mean cuz to me
like I'm not like us I'm saying I'm
curvy but I showed it to this boy and I
was just like look at this I was really
upset and he's arts laughing so hard I
was like
mother do black guy and he was just like
because nobody actually was a really
good thing I'm just kidding because he's
just like look at this he's like this is
hilarious just reason is I think like
your mate is genuinely effect
oh my god what am I gonna do classic
that's like that guy classic that guy
every guy knows that we need to find it
not that guy for you
this guy I'm over invite all over oh
yeah right
but what's funny is like I actually am
so opposed to relationship I say it all
the time I'm serious about it because
the way I see it is right now our
relationship only ends two ways you're
either gonna break up and it's gonna be
dramatic and it's gonna be stressful or
you're gonna be with that person the
rest of your life and you're going to
invest a lot of time and energy loving
to that person and right now I don't
really have like the time or emotion
takfir you ordered for them to take for
me I I love being single right now I
need that but sometimes [ __ ] is just
like hey know me you know I guess I
guess you can kind of have that
mentality which is good cuz you're
focused in your career and honestly I
agree well yeah it is it's a career and
like you know for me I when I met Jenna
I was nothing about girls at all like I
was working a ton I was going to school
and then I met her and then it kind of
just changes when you meet that person
it just like you know you can't really
we just got real people no but I'm just
saying like you absolutely identify with
that mindset of like you want to be
focused you can't be in a relationship
like it'll just kind of slow you or
whatever and then you meet that person
and you don't really understand what
anything is something that's what are
you hearing everything okay I think I'm
hearing
we're I ruined no this is a work in
progress but anyway I feel it yeah well
I'm like echoing in like a hundred
different yeah yeah maybe that means we
should end yeah yeah it's the special
guest headphones well thank you Gabi's
headphones but mostly Thank You Gabi for
coming on the podcast yeah really
enjoyed having you guys you guys can
follow Gabi on vine and Twitter and
YouTube we're gonna ladies yeah be show
the gabbie show on all that stuff
she's clearly epic an electric and a
great storyteller so check her stuff out
anytime you want me to talk about myself
or last conversation have out there
she'll be well be back next Monday
thanks guys for watching and thanks
everyone who's sick for who has sent
stuff in and who's going to send stuff
in we really appreciate it because it's
gonna go in the wall you know keep it in
anyway I will see you guys next week
have a good week have a good Monday
[Music]
[Music]